[MUSIC]
Because this orientation is prerecorded
for use semester after semester,
we're not going to spend much time
talking about things that will
change fairly often.
For example, we won't talk about
specializations, course offerings, and
curricula because those all
change semester to semester,
especially as the program is growing.
Instead, there are several websites
that contain up-to-date information on
the program, and we've provided links
to those in the instructor notes below.
We recommend checking out
the OMSCS program website for
information on graduation
requirements and course offerings.
You can check out the registrar's
website for calendars,
payment information, and
other general Georgia Tech policies.
And you should make sure to
check your email often, for
messages from your advisors and
your professors.